this is the Quan viso extend Pro modular
quad display system which is perfect for
Windows laptops and MacBooks giving you
the best possible multitasking
experience with three high quality
displays that are easy to connect and
set up boost in your productivity and
efficiency in just seconds with the Plug
and Play click and lock mounting
solution meant for digital Nomads who
want to work anywhere without being
limited to Just One display for years
there hasn't really been a great
solution for offering multiple displays
on a laptop other than buying them
separately and setting them up in your
office but there are two big issues with
that buying separate monitors gets
insanely expensive and they're basically
stuck to your office desk instead of
being portable and those are the issues
the Quan viso xn Pro sets out to solve
giving you three lightweight but high
quality IPS displays that all run at
1920 by 1200 resolution and and for a
great price of a hundred ninety nine
dollars within the first 24 hours of
their Kickstarter Crown funding launch
so definitely use the link below to
order today so with that said you can
essentially have four different apps or
Pages open at once with quick and
convenient multitasking dragging and
dropping files between the displays just
like you would with any other kind of
multi-display setup but my favorite
setup would probably be to have a Google
Docs script open on the left display a
YouTube video playing on the right and a
video editing viewer on the top which is
super unique and useful all while
editing the actual videos on the main
laptops display and even better this
setup is extremely modular allowing you
to set these displays up vertically if
you prefer portrait instead for doing
things like browsing the web or
especially viewing code it's basically
meant to give you the ultimate
flexibility allowing you to use all
three displays in any orientation
whenever you want or you can see simply
use two of them or just one if that's
all you need at the moment each display
is adjustable in terms of the viewing
angle so you can keep them flat or angle
them towards you or even away from you
if you want to show some content off to
somebody else and they're all very
lightweight as well it's perfect for
creating a mobile office basically
anywhere you're at whether you're in the
office at home or on an airplane or
coffee shop it boosts your productivity
everywhere conviso also sent over a
travel bag which has separated sections
for each display and pockets for the
cable so it's super convenient to carry
around and it's going to be available to
purchase as an add-on on their
Kickstarter page so with that said
before I get into my thoughts on how it
all works and what I like the most about
it let me get into explaining how easy
it is to get it set up it all starts
with the aluminum alloy frame attachment
that easily opens up to accept the
laptop anywhere from 11.6 to 16 inches
in size and it comes with a built-in
kickstand to support the weight of all
three displays without putting any
stress on the laptop's display as you
can see there are slots on both sides
and the top which is their modular
connector for the displays now simply
grab one of the displays choose where
you want to mount it unfold the
connector and slide it in until you hear
the click and Bam it's connected and as
you can see it's very stable now on both
sides of each display you have a USBC
Port which is where you'll connect the
included cable and then simply plug it
into your laptop and let the drivers
install now if you're on a MacBook an
additional quick plug-in download is
required to get it running then simply
do the same thing for the other two
displays and there you go you have a
quad screen laptop set up for ultimate
productivity and multitasking now making
it even better Quan viso included a USBC
Hub in the box when they sent it to me
allowing me to plug all three displays
into the Hub itself so that there would
only be one cable going into the laptop
freeing up the rest of the cables the
they did mention that the Cub currently
only has three ports for the display
since it's a prototype but the final
product will have more ports if you
choose to buy it as an add-on including
up to 10 ports and then finally when
you're done with your work or whatever
else just push the square release button
in the back to disengage the locking
mechanism so you can pull each display
off so all in all this setup was very
easy and simple and now with my final
thoughts of course these displays aren't
as good as the original laptop display
in terms of the brightness and contrast
but they do the job especially if you're
simply using the displays for things
like coding browsing the web or work
related tasks like writing scripts and
researching which is what I would use it
for it's surprisingly solid and sturdy
even with three displays attached at
once with all the weight resting on the
built-in stand and I love how the Hub
allows you to just have one cable
plugged into the laptop itself so you
have the ports left over for other
things and in general everything just
works smoothly so if you're looking to
get a modular quad monitor setup to
improve your productivity for a great
price or even if you just need one or
two additional displays you can
pre-order them using the link in the
video description and pinned comment
below if you enjoyed this video you can
subscribe above and check out one of
those two videos right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]
foreign